Chris froze get to see your brother good
to see you I know you've had Malhar on
the show bunch of hands I'm curious with
for a guy who doesn't work with him
every day yes how do you process what
comes out of his mouth because it's not
English it's like it's I call it malari
Lawry's so for me it's easy like I've
worked with him every day for the last
eight plus baseball season's does it
come across as gibberish I here's what
we do we do things on a curve around
here this um while I was away last week
we had as a guest host your Boise wish
was here nick swisher being here so you
know again we're on a curve right I
would guess that that that the the apex
of the curve is swish yeah and either on
the way up or on the way down we find
Millar yeah so I then turned that back
to you and say would that be inaccurate
it's interesting because Nick Swisher
will always have a special place in our
heart on intentional talk he was our
first ever guest kidding yeah he came
out with what I mean your voice was you
just wind him up and let him go he was
so excited like bro Rosie Millar God
yeah
your show is gonna be awesome man and he
just doesn't stop dude when he one of my
favorite moments of the last year in
baseball for sure was when he was given
the task of announcing the latest
Yankees draft choice and the kid who was
drafted was named bro BR EA ux is one of
my probably sure billing been the guy to
announce it
there's no bro bro he was broke he's not
a real good your happy guy after what
happened in London by the way oh my gosh
yes I here's my concern about the New
York Yankees is that they don't have the
starting pitching come October and they
don't have the hitting to survive
somebody like Verlander and somebody
like oh no no that the guys have holes
in their swings from the right side that
anybody you can go up and in and pound
these IRS's over
world baseball diamonds got it you know
all sorts of bullpen issues over there
he started with a full head of hair at
the beginning of the season look I
understand I'm waterskiing behind yachts
here and I'm talking about in them
before the all-star break it's July the
3rd I already know October's gonna
happen and you need to fine-tune things
and not only find two things but for
whom yeah you're gonna who might face so
and also like a buddy of mine is like do
we get Madison Bumgarner do we go out
and get him if and I'm like let me think
if we're planning for October right now
is the best October pitcher of our
generation potentially available yeah
you go get him I would go get a guy that
right I would get somebody different I
love Madison Bumgarner
I think somebody different works for the
gang like who well they're just you know
you could that's that I would high power
I would I Marcus Stroman I would I guys
that are going to be with you not only
this year but next year as well and okay
and could dominate I mean you have to
remember the Bauer a couple years ago in
the postseason really took it to the Red
Sox in game one of the divisional series
he's nuts though but he's a good he's
never seen anything quite like him in
baseball circles I mean he goes into his
little pitching lab in the offseason and
creates new pitches and he but you know
what he posts up man I think New York
would be fascinated by a guy like that
some people are like you know he'd scare
everybody off but I think he's he makes
every start dude
Madison Bumgarner is available and you
trot him out in October certainly after
the first half of the season when you've
acquired him everybody thinks that he's
kind of gassed anyway right now his last
three starts he's in terrible that's I
mean yeah now his last three he's been
he's shown some great stuff where the
Dodgers cuffed him up in a way that has
never seen before true so yes that's why
I'm like go just go just go fine you'll
be fine
but the Dodgers are terrific in their
own right they're great the Dodgers are
fantastic if I had to rank the team's 1
through 30 yes just based on their
ability to win in October the Yankees
are one though they're make it happen
yes
because they could have a starter that
goes four innings and they could still
coast they just no no we'll see we'll
see I think the Dodgers are better this
year than they have old early previous
years
well that that trade and you know of
Kemp and queeg freed things up in the
outfield net amazing where Bellinger's
plant you know he played all 162 games
last year but he only started
I think 132 that guy had to be in the
lineup everyday I didn't I never quite
understood that right it's also allowed
Alex Verdugo to finally have an everyday
place in that lineup and he's been
fantastic he was a borderline all-star I
think so you know I listen are we gonna
go back to 1977 78 81 Dodgers Yankees it
wouldn't suck for baseball I could tell
you as for as far as the Yankees I'm
fine about going back to 77 and 78 1981
I would not so good no I'd like to talk
about well I'd like to avoid that one I
cried myself to sleep at the end of that
World Series because I knew Reggie
Jackson was gonna leave the Yankees and
my that was my guy growing up yeah
literally cried myself to sleep and then
I cried more when uh Dave Winfield was
called mr. May by George Steinbrenner
after that Cleveland's finest to George
Steinbrenner the third you know and and
by the way can I just tell you that as
you were crying yourself to sleep after
having a World Series experience for the
third time in five years the Cleveland
Indians did not finish higher than
fourth in their division the first 23
years of my life
can you digest that for a minute say
that he knows how bad your franchise has
to be to not like you can't lock into a
third place finish and the American
League East that's what they were in at
the time right you know the 17th
division they didn't fish higher than
fourth
there were times where I would go down
to ball games at old Cleveland Municipal
Stadium and would show up and would have
conversations with the left fielder
because there were so few people in the
stands there was a guy named Jack
Daugherty who was like a reserve
outfielder for the Rangers and we were
having a game where there were a couple
of balls thrown high and tie two guys
and I was like hey Jack there's gonna be
a fight and he turned around he started
throwing fists and stuff he was talking
to us i was like hey Jack we need a
fourth for golf tomorrow
do you have time he's like no I gotta be
at the ballpark that's how bad it Carter
one time in left-field turn he sneezed a
lady
said bless you he turned around and said
thank you how does that happen
51 years between first place finishes
you know it's amazing
Chris Rose here on the Rich Eisen show I
remember the cover of Sports Illustrated
my freshman year in college at Michigan
when I was in the dorm and Mary Markley
dorm shout out Harry barber there it did
you know you did not you know I went
there for a year I did not come on I did
not did you really go there you went
there for one year before I transferred
oh that's for the Rich Eisen show after
dark story the white race I did not know
about that so we're in same dorm Cory
Schneider and Joe Carter were on the
cover and he is uprising yes and what it
was and everybody thought here it's
finally gonna happen 1986 is when it was
in 1986 that was at the end of my mom so
in 1987 I guess at the end of my for my
first year is 86 days lost 100 games a
year oh my god
61 and 101 you must be excited going to
the all-star game that is in Cleveland
Ohio that'll be great
and then the draft we're gonna get the
draft in Cleveland Oh on a couple this
is a big deal for my city and it's a big
deal for me personally I'm bringing
Michele and Josh and Brady they've been
to several all-star games but this is
the first time I actually get to go to
an all-star game in Cleveland it was
there in 1981 when I was 10 and I was at
away at Camp Roosevelt I mean every good
Jewish parents sends their kid away to
summer camp in suburban Cleveland Ohio
so I was at Camp Roosevelt which I hated
that summer and I remember they visited
me the day of the all-star game and I
begged them to take me and I was like
please and they're like yeah you're at
camp I was like boot camp socks
redeemable quality about this camp like
I want to go there like yeah we paid for
it sorry you're gonna be here yeah and
my brother whom you you've met Pierce
yes and Chris Rose his brother's name is
Pete its Pete after Pete no he was I
think Pete Rose had just finished his
his
fourth major league season finished it
us Jews don't name that kids have to
Petros yeah we didn't do that but they
took Pete and so Pete got to go and I
was like what am I ever gonna get to go
to an all-star game and now this I think
will be my 15th straight so congrats on
that it's awesome that'll be that'll be
great
and on the home run derby I think it's
awesome that yellow cheese participate
in it Brewers fans are freaking out
though they are freaking and he went out
on Twitter and said hey everybody just
slow your roll be fine baseball neat I'm
sick and tired of the baseball needs
conversation what what does baseball
need Chris Rose do they need anything I
actually think the games in a really
good place when you look at the great
young talent that we've got out there I
mean I'm talking about the stars that
are under the age of 25 you'll see a few
of them in Cleveland next week I mean
Ronald Acuna jr. the Braves there's a
guy they just inked to a hundred million
dollar deal right even though he had
less than a year service time and the
Braves probably saved themselves between
150 and 200 million dollars he's that
good
Fernando Tati's jr. who arguably could
have made the all-star team of course
his dad as famous for hitting two grand
slams in an inning this kid is his
lights out his lights out ability and
instincts he's already scored twice this
year from third base on a pop-up to
second yeah we saw that the other day
yeah tagged up from third on a pop-up to
second Yahoo it's crazy it's it's unreal
so the game threw a 94 mile an hour seed
from the hole the other yeah it's it's
ridiculous his talent so as far as the
talent that's on the field and the
personalities hopefully you're seeing
that and on shows like ours you know
we're like you guys we try and talk to
the players of so they're human beings
that's correct
and they're not just athletes I loved
Bregman I love this just again we need
to hear from more of them we do and
here's mom they got a call in to more
shows like this one yours you know yeah
and and get out there because once you
know it once July 31st hits once one
it's enough it's it's football season
and and football has more of a national
following there are more people in
certain parts of the country that will
watch a football game because maybe it's
fantasy maybe it is gambling I don't
know right but it just there's no
national following for baseball did
where somebody in Florida is just gonna
be interested in Brewers versus Mariners
minor league game you know it's just
it's very difficult these guys do have
star qualities and I think more and more
of them right are hopefully breaking
down walls on social media I think that
is happening I think you're gonna see it
a ton at the home run derby how much fun
they're having they're you know they're
bringing their cameras out and their
phones during games and and that sort of
stuff and so that is important to
continue to grow that brand and there's
no question that improvement needs to be
made but I also don't think that there's
a there's a hole well what's wrong with
baseball sort of deal I don't think it's
as bad off as everybody makes it out
well I really don't I would watch the
all-star game and Home Run Derby with my
two oldest boys but they're in summer
camp that's right you know I'm sending
my little one away for camp for two
weeks and I'm gonna be dreading it enjoy
that did you go to camp I did I did I
did I trails on camp and camp Locanda
and didn't enjoy much of it how many
years did you go oh God from 77 through
80 something uh-huh you know and I do
remember where I always do bunk what I
forget the bunk number but I was in my
bunk when I learned that Thurman Munson
it died and I will never forget that
moment
Chris Rose here on the Rich Eisen show
let's talk BattleBots yeah let's do it
why do you think this show is so damn
popular well I think this is gonna sound
cheesy but it's it's a show that the
whole family can watch it's true okay
and there's not a lot of those out there
there's there's shows that will appeal
to younger kids and the parents want
nothing to do with it there's more adult
type shows and you don't want your kids
watching that sort of stuff but this is
one where there's violence there's crazy
personalities and signs
blown up I know left and right I mean
things are on fire we have I mean look
at this sort of stuff like that that one
bought on the left there that thing's
called quantum and it looks like
something out of a Terminator movie
right right and it just sinks its teeth
into that
called lockjaw and these bots have crazy
personality and TV doesn't do these
things justice these are 250 pound
machines yes that their blades sometimes
they're spinning 250 miles an hour and
Kenny Florian who's who's our analysts
the of our UFC fighter yep awesome dude
we're sitting Bach side and so we have
stuff that's flying right at our head
several hundred miles an hour that
part's not as funny Richard quantum
versus lockjaw I'm seeing video of it
right here what's your favorite name a
battle bot name that's come across your
ear gate tease and Michael Irvin phrase
well I mean listen there's some classic
battle bots out there like tombstone
he's the biggest baddest bot on the
block and it I mean the way it sounds is
the way it comes out it is a simple bot
where the blade is just nasty and just
cuts through stuff all the time you know
as far as a good name I mean we saw duck
which sounds so simple and it is pretty
like duck like what type of really like
that's a battle bot bot yeah like it's
so cute and stuff but that thing is it's
ridiculous my favorite bot though is the
thing called Bronco which flips these
robots 20 feet in the air and it has
this hydraulic lift on it that just pops
it up it's great it's crazy stuff if you
never seen it before this show has more
whoa per capita than most I turn into
the Gus Johnson robot three minutes so
if you could just scream at the top of
your lungs
woah yeah and make this expression then
you're good okay I have a few more
minutes left here so let's get to it
I will give you the floor on this the
Browns in 2019 excited or nervous wasn't
David and Joe COO right here in this
year you might it might still be
indented I was from his posture I was
gonna say yes this is great
nervously excited no is that good you
mix them both that's it's like it's like
a meals pick one I'm excited you should
be kind
we're excited because you know again I
don't think this is the football version
of Cory Schneider and Joe Carter on the
cover of smells like this is legit yeah
we saw
towards the end of last year some legit
forget pulse like signs of dangers watch
the games on Sunday how often would you
sit in the back and you're like Chris
Rose how about those Cleveland Browns
now you would mock me for years Browns
up on our big screen we have a great
viewing situation and that was to put
him up there right because whenever the
Browns would go on the big screen in
years past something disastrous would
have right yes and so I would words
would put him up there your bug course
words and I would say Worth's what are
you doing to me and I would give you
grief because you got a gig on the
center screen things can beat things
cannot when you go oh and 16 there's no
owning anything I should say I share
your DNA and trap door construe I mean
jet fans and Browns friends very
concerned and trust me the last year
week three NFL Network and Fox Thursday
night have all the Jets put their young
buck chosen third overall in the draft
because the first overall pick in the
draft at the time was considered too
young and too green to start so to Rod
Taylor trots out there
the Jets young quarterback looks like
the young quarterback the Browns young
quarterback gets in the game because
Hugh Jackson was forced to finally put
him in there and then the world opened
up in a manner that has not opened up
for the Browns true who have put hopes
and players like the ones that the Jets
have put in Sam Donald congratulations
Odell has come I know my concern is
again that Freddie kitchens in the
crucible of choosing timeouts and when
to take them and using challenges
moments of four minutes three minutes
two minutes to go we'll have some
learning curve issues I get it I
understand all that
I would say if you could have
hand-picked a head coach in the off
season of the guys that were available
where would you have gone no I would
have stuck with him because he works
clearly with Baker may fright he
definitely showed that he's got the
stripes but that's the point isn't it is
it you could have if you had taken Mike
McCarthy let's just
there would have been a whole nother
side of the tractors that would have
said oh wait look what happened with his
offensive scale in Green Bay right
you're gonna go with it you know guy
where maybe the game is past and by a
little so there would have been that you
know group of people that wouldn't have
been happy so they just they have to own
this and there will be some growing
pains with him as a head coach is it
just there was inevitable successful
season would look like what that heading
into December with a fairly soft
schedule going in which means at Arizona
home against Baltimore in Cincinnati
twice says that they have seven wins
going into that month that means that
they're they'll have a real good shot of
playing in genuine love that that spoken
like a true bronze that unbelievable six
and we make the playoffs just I just
want seven wins going it's not the Rose
way which happened by the way with Brian
Hoyer beating the bangles on Thursday
Night Football for that was that that
was the Xena that was an era I was there
for it not that Mike Pettine era by the
way that's the Josh Rose era who's
almost 19 years old four more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 under red TV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app